digamos que tienes curiosidad por
estudiar las dimensiones de los carros
que están estacionados en el
estacionamiento así que mide su longitud
es hagamos esto sencillo supongamos que
sólo hay cinco carros ajá entonces de
esta manera nuestra población consiste
sólo en cinco carros y mide sus
dimensiones supongamos que el primero
mide cuatro metros el segundo carro mide
4 puntos 2 metros otro carro mide 5
metros y otro mide 4 puntos 3 metros el
cuarto carro mide o no el quinto carro
mide 5.5 metros 5.5 metros y ok muy bien
así que inventemos algunos parámetros
para esta población lo primero que
queremos o que nos gustaría conocer es
la medida de la tendencia central así
que tal vez la más popular sería la
media aritmética iniciemos con eso vamos
a iniciar calculando la media aritmética
para esta población así que
no es igual a cuál es la media
aritmética aquí simplemente sumamos
estos y lo dividimos entre 5 el total de
la suma así que sacó la calculadora para
que sea un poco más rápido y entonces
tenemos 4 + 4.2 + 54.3 + 5.5 y esta suma
la voy a dividir entre 5 entre 5 esto me
da 4.6 es la media aritmética para mi
población así que me es igual a 4.6 eso
está excelente pongamos unidad de medida
son 4.6 metros y esa es la tendencia
central así que tal vez también quizás
tengamos curiosidad de saber qué tan
dispersos están los datos especialmente
con respecto a la tendencia central y
que usaremos para esto ya tenemos una
herramienta a nuestra disposición para
eso que es nuestra varianza poblacional
y la varianza poblacional es una
una de las muchas herramientas para
medir la dispersión tienen tienen
algunas propiedades tienen unas
propiedades bastante elegantes y por eso
la definimos como la media de las
distancias al cuadrado de la media y ok
entonces es una muy buena herramienta
así que usemos la calculemos la varianza
poblacional para esta población entonces
lo que lo que necesitamos hacer es
encontrar las distancias a cada uno de
estos a nuestra media la cual es 4.6
después elevarlas al cuadrado y tomar
después de eso la media de esas
distancias al cuadrado así que hagamos
eso será será 4 menos 4 puntos 6 al
cuadrado más 4.2 menos 4 puntos 6 al
cuadrado más 5 menos 4.6 al cuadrado más
4.3 menos 4 puntos 6 al cuadrado más
estoy aquí sin espacio
+ 5.5 menos 4.6 al cuadrado y esto lo
vamos a dividir todo entre 5 para
obtener nuestra varianza poblacional
entre 5 entonces seguimos 44.6 cuánto es
eso
4 - 4 puntos 6 al cuadrado es igual a
menos punto 6 al cuadrado pero es lo
mismo que punto 6 al cuadrado 0.6 al
cuadrado más 4.2 menos 4 puntos 6 al
cuadrado es igual a menos punto 4 al
cuadrado pero el signo negativo no
importa porque estamos elevando al
cuadrado así que es más punto 4 al
cuadrado luego 5 menos 4.6 al cuadrado
es igual a punto 4 al cuadrado
4.3 menos 4.6 al cuadrado es igual a
menos
- punto 3 al cuadrado pero es lo mismo
que punto 3 al cuadrado ajá y 5.5 menos
4.6 al cuadrado es igual a punto 9 al
cuadrado todo esto lo vamos a dividir
entre 5 y que nos va a dar nos da igual
a punto 316 entonces esto es igual a 0.3
16 muy bien hasta aquí vamos excelente
ahora te voy a preguntar algo que bueno
a mí me resulta muy muy interesante la
pregunta es cuál sería la unidad de
medida para esta varianza poblacional o
que hice aquí observas tenemos 4.6
metros estamos usando metros entonces
esto aquí sería cuatro metros 4.6 metros
metros metros cinco metros todos estos
son metros
y estamos midiendo en metros aquí cuando
los restas también
obtienes metros y cuando los elevas al
cuadrado obtienes metros cuadrados como
puedes observar y después lo vas a
dividir entre entre 5 el cual es un
número sin medida entonces aquí tendrías
0.3 16 metros cuadrados así que tú tal
vez tú pienses eso pero esto parece algo
parece una unidad de medida extraña
porque si quiero la dispersión con
respecto a la media cuando yo lo
visualizo yo pienso en metros no metros
cuadrados entonces que podemos hacer
aquí una buena pista sería simplemente
observa este signo este signo está
elevado al cuadrado entonces porque no
simplemente tomamos tomamos la raíz
cuadrada de sigma al cuadrado y ya está
cierto así que hagamos eso tomamos la
raíz cuadrada de sigma al cuadrado lo
cual es en nuestra varianza poblacional
y esto es igual a sigma tiene mucho
sentido ahora entonces sigma
igual aquí es igual veamos es la raíz
cuadrada de 0.3 16 y cuál será la unidad
de medida para esto solamente vamos a
tener metros entonces tomó la raíz
cuadrada de cero 0.3 16 y esto es igual
a punto 5 62 entonces lo redondeo lo voy
a dejar
de esta manera entonces esto es
aproximadamente 0.5 62 metros y tal vez
tú pienso te preguntes ok esto como se
llama qué nombre tiene la raíz cuadrada
de la varianza poblacional aquí aún no
hemos hecho muestreos la raíz cuadrada
de la varianza poblacional eso tiene que
nombre tiene
ok está esto es muy familiar de hecho
recuerda este nombre porque seguro viene
en un examen
esta es la famosísima desviación
estándar poblacional está la desviación
estándar poblacional es una medida
a medida que nos informa sobre la
varianza de los datos con respecto a la
media en general mientras más grande sea
este valor quiere decir que los datos
varían más con respecto a la media eso
quiere decir y lo contrario entre más
pequeño sea este número entonces eso nos
dice que la varianza es menor con
respecto a la media y estas son son de
alguna manera definiciones arbitrarias
de cómo definimos varianza podríamos tal
vez quizás elevar las a la cuarta
potencia o o tomar el valor absoluto en
lugar de elevar elevar las alguna
potencia pero la razón por la que
hacemos esto es que tiene ciertas
propiedades que le quedan como anillo al
dedo la estadística eso es pero en fin
esto es la desviación estándar
poblacional fue en metros esta respuesta
y en el próximo vídeo veremos desviación
estándar muestral así que nos vemos
pronto
bye